[Music]
yes tonight's a comedian an actor who
stars on Sullivan & Son which can be
seen Thursday nights at 10:00 right here
on TBS please welcome back to the show
that very funny Roy Wood jr. yeah my
uncle which I understand people you ever
have somebody give you a gift that
they're proud of but you're looking at
the gift like why would you would you
buy me my uncle gave me a $50 gift card
with $12 left on the hero -38 now I
gotta do math it was 50 but I left the
house I have to stop and get some gas so
I'm sorry I don't understand people man
I'm from Birmingham Alabama I live in LA
now and no one tells you before you come
to LA is that the gangs are still
serious they're very serious in LA they
get mad if you wear the wrong color in
the wrong here's the problem with being
black there's a lot of problems with
being black here's one of the problems
with being black is that if you wear the
wrong color shirt in the wrong hood the
gang dude wanted to fight me I'm wearing
the red it was a nice but why can't I
wear a red shirt again I'm 34 I'm
allowed to wear a normal color shirt
again sir why are you in my face what
who are you claiming what who are you
claiming I'm claiming adulthood
[Applause]
[Music]
how could you possibly confuse me Emily
gang obviously I'm a supervisor you're
out of line look cousin Derrick got
Marik's girl Tasha in Baton Rouge
I just went to the wedding I don't
understand I understand marriage but
it's the forever part that I can't just
speak to the kids get out of college
just high five we did a good job is a
long time that's what I don't think my
cousin understands I don't think most
men understand what forever looks like
most men start running off at the mouth
well you know man people be getting
married forever since the beginning the
time everybody got it 30 it makes X 27
with a bad coffee yeah go ahead and
settle down you got three years left you
have to do that anymore we got nyquil
and penicillin you're gonna be here a
while this is what most men forget is
that women work harder at a relationship
than a man ever will hands down there's
no competition
a woman will do everything in her power
to make a relationship work does it
matter what the circumstances are you
don't believe me watch a television show
called The Walking Dead it's the best
example I can give you great show great
show you never watch The Walking Dead
pretty simple premise zombies take over
the earth everybody's running from the
zombies that's dust it's deeper than
that but that's the basic gesture though
Eddie come on that's pretty much the
gist
of the show and in the show this is the
best example I can give you a dedication
to a marriage there's this black dude
first episode of the show so black dude
with his son they're the only people in
the neighborhood to not get caught by
the zombies they go out during the day
they scurry around to gather supplies
ammunition whatever they need to stay
alive - the next day they go home at
sunset because that's when the zombies
come out they board up the windows they
turn off the lights
they blockade the door they do
everything they can to remain silent
so that the zombies can't hear them and
it works for the most part but one night
he has a knocking at the door and he
gets his gun and he creeps up to the
door he puts his son behind him and he
looks up through the peephole of the
door and on the other side of the door
is his dead zombie wife that's what
forever
she's a zombie
he'll try to make it work
[Applause]